vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le drame et
la colère au sénégal après la mort de
onze bébés dans un incendie dans une
maternité dans l'ouest du pays le
président macky sall a décrété trois
jours de deuil national à partir de ce
jeudi et le ministre de la santé a été
démissionné reportage à suivre dès le
début de ce journal
la fièvre de la vallée du rift détecté
pour la première fois au burundi une
maladie qui attaque les bovins et qui a
déjà emporté plus de 500 vaches une
catastrophe pour des milliers de
burundais qui vivent de l'élevage
[Musique]
notre invité de ce soir c'était
bodhisattva un didier centrafricains qui
a gagné la reconnaissance des
producteurs avec son ancestrale sol un
mélange d'après haus aux influences
disco et il nous a expliqué ce que
c'était ex extrait de notre entretien à
suivre dans cette édition
on ouvre ce journal par l'horreur qui a
frappé la ville de tivaouane dans
l'ouest du sénégal ce mercredi un
incendie s'est déclaré dans une
maternité un premier bilan fait état de
onze bébés morts un court circuit serait
le point de départ du sinistre un drame
qui a une nouvelle fois met en lumière
les carences du système de santé
sénégalais et précision et le reportage
nos correspondants sarah sakho et les
mandats
c'est au deuxième étage de ce bâtiment
que le drame a eu parmi les onze nouveau
né mort dans les flammes on rame à trois
semaines son père est trop ému pour
parler il est en deuil pour la seconde
fois la maman du bébé est décédé pendant
l'accouchement la famille désemparée ah
ça c'est un fait mal simplement on
arrivait un premier à me disant qu' il
ya 110 ici dans l'hôpital le
bébé était déjà parti
devant l'hôpital proche des simples
curieux sont venus témoigner leur
solidarité
la ville a assisté au départ de flammes
avant l'arrivée des pompiers
on a essayé par tous les moyens
d'éteindre le feu
j'ai pu prendre un inspecteur mais il ne
marchait pas
lorsqu'on a enfin ouvert la porte du
service néonatal il y avait de la fumée
partout
on a vu l'horreur
ce drame intervient quelques semaines à
peine après la mort à l'hôpital d'une
jeune maman victime de négligences
médicales franchement on demande à
l'état du sénégal de prendre ses
responsabilités le faire une enquête
mais aussi de situer les responsabilités
et de pour faire les sanctions idoine
le ministre de la santé indique une
enquête a été ouverte
il faut noter que nous attendons le
rapport d'expert technique de la senelec
nous édifier sur l'origine du fort
je vais donc devoir de ce point de vue
la manne arrêté là parce que à l'état
actuel de la situation nous ne pouvons
pas aller plus loin que ça pour rendre
hommage aux victimes
un deuil national a été décrétée pour
trois jours à partir de ce jeudi
on l'a appris dans le journal la
télévision sénégalaise le ministre de la
santé a été démissionné suite à ce drame
les africains sont de plus en plus
nombreux à mourir du cancer en cause une
vie plus sédentarisées un régime
alimentaire - saint ogan à un
laboratoire a lancé un grand projet
archives et les quatre cancers en
afrique afin de mieux connaître la
maladie et trouver des traitements plus
adapté aux malades sur les sites dont
les chiffres ne sont pas bons
le cancer progresse en afrique et le
taux de malades qui succombent est parmi
les plus élevés dans le monde un
laboratoire basé à accra a décidé de se
lancer dans un projet pharaonique il
compte révolutionner la recherche sur le
cancer en afrique
le labourier machy s'intéresse aux
concerts notamment parce que personne
d'autre ne le fait en afrique la plupart
des chercheurs se consacre aux maladies
infectieuses et pourtant notre continent
est celui où le poids du cancer
progresse le plus vite
baisser la mortalité commence par le
fait de tester les gens et détecter les
cancers très tôt pour qu'ils puissent
être traitées ces scientifiques ont une
autre approche il crée une base de
données sur les cancers à travers
l'afrique pour en avoir une image très
précise
lorsque l'on regarde les études faites à
travers le monde une très petite partie
des patients examinés sont africains
notre but est d'étudier la population
africaine
c'est important parce que sans cette
étude nous n'aurions pas assez de
données sur le cancer du sein chez les
africains
rassembler les données cruciales parce
que cela va permettre d'ajuster les
traitements aux africains pour plus
d'efficacité plus de vies sauvées après
le cancer du sein le laboratoire va se
consacrer au cancer chez les enfants
et on passe au reste de l'actualité en
bref et en images
une cinquantaine de civils ont été tués
dans l'est du burkina faso lors d'une
attaque menée par des djihadistes
présumés les habitants ont été pris pour
cible alors qu'il tentait de fuir la
localité de mode you are y placer sous
blocus par les djihadistes des combats
ont eu lieu ce mercredi entre l'armée
congolaise et le mouvement rebelle du
m23 coup près de goma du millier
d'habitants ont fui les combats et ils
seraient environ 10000 ces derniers
jours avoir quitté à la hâte leurs
villages du regroupement de kibumba
selon le rapport du bureau de
coordination des affaires humanitaires
des nations unies
le nom des prochains protagonistes de la
prochaine présidentielle de l'an
prochain au nigeria seront bientôt
connus une primaire ce week end va
désigner le candidat du parti au pouvoir
la pc et dont le président actuel est
issu bolatti migou ancien gouverneur de
lego espère remporter les primaires
après deux mandats - ou de boire et de
son côté lui va quitter le pouvoir sa
succession s'annonce très disputé
pour la première fois la fièvre de la
vallée du rift a été détecté au burundi
depuis fin avril plus de 500 vaches sont
déjà été emportées par cette maladie qui
est signalé aujourd'hui dans plus de la
moitié du territoire national sur les 18
provinces 10 sont déjà affectés c'est la
panique générale chez les milliers de
burundais qui vivaient de l'élevage des
vaches wassim cornes
sur le site d'élevage de nyanga au sud
de bujumbura les éleveurs sont dans la
tourmente
nous avons peur cette maladie n'a pas de
médicaments impossible de ne pas
paniquer
face à la propagation de la fièvre de la
vallée du rift et pour éviter que leurs
troupeaux ne soit décimée les éleveurs
demandent que leurs bovins soit vaccinée
pour éviter le pire nous demandons dans
l'urgence qu'on ferme tous les marchés
des bovins comme c'est déjà fait dans
certaines régions et puis il faut
procéder à la vaccination de nos
troupeaux
de son côté le gouvernement est à
l'oeuvre pour faire face à la
propagation de la maladie en attendant
de rendre disponible un dispositif de
prévention et de soins le ministère de
l'environnement de l'agriculture et de
l'élevage a déjà pris certaines mesures
dont l'interdiction de l'abattage ou le
transport de tous ruminants ils
appellent les éleveurs à la vigilance
les élèves et doivent informer les
services techniques de tous les cas
cliniques pour les prises hh la clv ans
et de l'évolution de la maladie continue
à tous les niveaux dans les zones
touchées la description du tout nouveau
mât pour les mineurs et l'interdiction
de l'abattage doivent être respectées
jusqu'à nous verrons
les symptômes de cette maladie sont
nombreux saignements nasale faiblesse
fausse couche et inappétence qui aboutit
à la mort les premiers cas ont été
rapportés dans les provinces
frontalières avec le rwanda avant de se
propager vers d'autres zones
les nations unies estiment que quelque
2500 langues à travers le monde sont
menacées de disparition
parmi elles il y a le memic parler
parler bdic au sud est du sénégal pour
sauver cette langue béni fadi un
chanteur se bat avec comme seule arme la
musique nos correspondants sans brad
pitt eli man down ça à sakho se sont
rendus au village de bandafassi pour le
rencontrer
benoît faber est en mission à 36 ans ce
chanteur se bat pour sauver sa langue le
médical mais le cola et
le milieu barry que dans cette région
rurale et sud est du sénégal et le
compte moins de 4000 locuteurs chaque
année moins nombreux c'est une
catastrophe quand même de voir
disparaître mais je le dis souvent je
dis que ce serait pas bien de ma part
chanter dans sa langue pour la perpétuer
l'initiative de benoît est très apprécié
à bandafassi son village d'origine
ce forgeron traditionnel un but puis
espoir grâce à lui
je remercie benoît et l'encouragent dans
sa dynamique si aujourd'hui la langue
mini continue de résister c'est en
grande partie grâce à lui on est trop
vieux pour faire quelque chose c'est aux
jeunes de mener le combat benoît est une
star à bandafassi mais son ambition ne
s'arrête pas là
à 700 kilomètres de son village à dakar
la capitale son premier concert se tait
à guichet fermé
dans un style électro aulnoye coquine
public cosmopolite
qui dansent pour la première fois sur
une musique 1 minute
à ce qu'a dit que tout ce monde là
[Musique]
c'est joli comme tout le monde la
connaît donc gérer cela et
[Musique]
après dakar le musicien va partir à la
conquête de paris et berlin un joint
ce sera sa première tournée
internationale
eh ben on reste dans la musique et avec
un invité qui lui mélange des genres
musicaux très influencé par le son de
fela kuti il mélange une mais la musique
traditionnelle et modernité de la haus
il vient de la centrafrique du centre de
la centrafrique mais il a déjà conquis
le monde depuis plus de vingt ans qu'il
mixe didier bodhisattva merci des dans
le journal de france 24 laure sibon
souvent merci beaucoup alors on écoute
j'aimerais qu'on écoute parce que ça
s'écoute d'abord après on en parle un
morceau qui loulou extrait du dernier
alors on en parle juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a écouté on a écouté un extrait
ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est que nous
expliquer ce que c'est l'ancestrale sol
ce que l'on voulait finir ce genre
musical lancé sa sauce et avant tout je
la décris comme déjà un esprit musical
c'est c'est une identité
que j'écris pour me permettre de voyager
beaucoup plus tranquillement et
paisiblement à travers les différents
genres musicaux que moi j'aime donc ça
séduit pour pouvoir nbi
à la pop peu importe le genre musical
qui me plaît je voulais ne pas être
limité par un cadre défini qui serait
par exemple la house music la dipas ou
ou le rap par exemple qui finalement
fait que de nos jours c'est beaucoup
plus ouvert mais à l'époque en tous les
cas ça n'était pas donc l'ancestrale
sauce est aussi un son c'est aussi une
identité une identité très marqué sur un
tropisme forcément africains ou les
rythmiques sont traditionnellement des
africains c'est vraiment représente jeu
le spectre mais sur tout le continent ya
pas une zone spécifiquement qui
concernait parce que je je je dis je
touche musicalement est donc lancée sera
le saut c'est vraiment ça c'est un si je
doit simplifier la description c'est un
genre musical qui paie hommage à nos
origines ancestrales tout en
s'inscrivant dans une dans une vision du
futur et qui continue évoluer en
permanence alors parlons de vous et de
votre identité m'ont dit vous êtes né
blanc vous avez grandi en afrique avec
un quart de sang noir et que vous
vouliez préserver votre négritude alors
qu'en europe et aux états unis vous
étiez vu comme blanc oui oui mais vous
savez mon père était mon père était
métis ma mère que je viens de perdre
était blanche américaine belge vos pairs
centrafricain français dont c'est vrai
que ce mélange étant des amandiers à
l'hôpital général ayant grandi à bria à
l'est en pays bande à moi qui suis baiia
de deux gains boula d'ombré toutes ces
choses là c'est les contradictions sont
pour beaucoup de gens qui finalement
moment à mon père m'a appris à m'amuser
de ces décès de ces choses là
et de ne pas se contrôler au sérieux par
contre d'être pleinement conscient de ma
couleur de peau qui clairement c'est
inévitable on peut pas on veut pas se
tromper par contre effectivement c'est
vrai que mon identité est profondément
africaine est certainement parce que
j'ai peut-être pas il n'y a pas de
mélanine donc ouais il fallait l'a clamé
à travers la musique à travers mon mama
mon amour pour le continent quoi de
manière générale mais oui je suis en
pleine équilibre et tout ça oui alors
comment dites nous comment ce comment
justement vous avez réussi à mettre tout
ça dans le prochain album qui sort le
mois prochain ah bah écoutez je peux
dire c'est un déjà c'est un stade n'a
pas manqué un peu un album fleuve 31
titres qui clôt une trilogie qui a
commencé avec mon premier album à
vocation le deuxième album de transition
et celui ci manifestation parce que je
pense que ma vie est vraiment un
parcours descriptif de tous ses albums
main et donc j'ai souhaité réunir toutes
mes influences dans ce projet je pouvais
pas le faire en moins de trente titres
l'internet aujourd'hui nous permet
d'être assez expérimentale avec tout ça
c'est une playlist vous pour la lancer
et puis vous avez l'occasion d'y revenir
quand vous voulez il ya tous les gens
amusez-vous il ya toi les gens merci
beaucoup vous dit ça doit d'être venu
sur le plateau de france 24 peut-être
même qu'on écoutera un petit peu à la
fin justement pour ce qui t on c'est
ainsi qu'on referme ce journal de
l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivis alors de bangui n'est ce pas à
paris en passant par le commerce la
ville rester avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24 on écoute un
petit bout en partant c'est possible on
va voir si on peut écouter un petit bout
de body sa gloire en partant
[Musique]
le mot ou deux
on doit que
[Musique]